hello everyone watching a chess
tournament broadcast live is highly
enjoyable but what makes the experience
even more enjoyable is good chess
commentary and when it comes to chess
commentary well Yaser is definitely the
chest commentary god and this game was
played in in 1982 and that's well before
yasser was a famous commentator and this
this was the time when Yasir crushed
world champions as this game meowser is
playing with white pieces against the
current world chess champion Anatoly
Karpov himself and it's it's a wonderful
game and a very interesting game but
even more interesting to me is the
reason why Karpov lost this game and the
Karpov himself said so but I will let
you know the reason after the game so
like I said yasser is white and he plays
a knight of three we have Knight to f6
and RC for an English opening we have e
6 and Knight to c3 d5 we have d4 by
yasser now transposing into the Queens
gambit declined
we have Bishop to e7 Bishop to g5 h6
Bishop to h4 Karpov castles and rook to
c1
I will be six preparing to develop that
light square bishop and here Yasser goes
for a series of exchanges
he plays see captors and e5 we have
night capture Sun d5 by carp of night
capture Sun d5e capture sandy fog and
out of captures on e7 Queen captures on
e7 and g3
Yasir is also preparing to develop for
the bishop to g2 we have grew up 38 now
of course counter harassing this e to
pony bishop to g2 is played so we have
erupted the c3 by a sir preparing either
Queen to c2 worry Queen to c1 or maybe
even a rook to e3 if the position allows
it Karpov plays Knight to a6 and here
Yaser immediately plays Queen to a for
now
no not allowing black to play to develop
the bishop on the King side well he
could play Bishop to d7 or something
like that but Karpov actually goes to c5
and allows allows yasser well well
allows the answer a great move which
Karpov actually allowed this wasn't a
blunder
yes sir plays rook to e3 and now as you
can see he's attacking Karpov Queen and
if the Queen moves then both Yas Queen
and rook are threatening to capture here
on e8 and well this would be losing is
if the Queen moves
so yes replayed a Karpov played Bishop
to e6
but now Esther can capture this pawn
freely this night on I a six freely he
plays Queen captures on a six and we
have a see capture Sundy for and well
the rook is attacked and this pawn
cannot be captured if not capture sandy
for then Queen to b4 with Czech picks up
this Knight and the black is better here
so after C capture sandy for yessir
plays rook to b3 now defending against
this Queen to b4 check and also it's
well the rook is fine here and Karpov
plays Bishop to f5 we have Bishop to G
to a developing and preparing to castle
and our Bishop - see - if carpet was an
attacking player he might have tried d3
here you know going for a full attack
but after e3 there's really nothing
black can hope for here so after Bishop
to g2 Karpov played Bishop to c2 now
attacking this rook and it's well if
carpet will try to defend this rook
wouldn't move like I don't know let's
say rook to a3
if Rockdale read and simply Queen to b4
now and after King moves or even night
to d2 then the Queen would capture this
B to pawn and black would have
sufficient compensation for the piece so
after this Bishop to see to move Yasser
actually played the night capture Sundy
for allowing the Karpov to capture -
rockin b3 so Karpov did Bishop captures
on b3 and night capture some b3 and now
the answer has a knight and the bishop
for a rook so a better position for
white definitely here we have a rook a
to c8
and Bishop to f3 the best move into
position totally nullifying this threat
of Queen captures an e2 and preparing to
castle
carpet plays rook to c2 if well white
wants the castle he will waste a move so
carpet will grab this b2 point so yessir
does he castles and carpet plays rook
capture
some be too but this rook captures and
Vito was actually a too important of a
temple for for carp of the waste now we
have rook to d1 by yasser attacking this
pawn here so rook the d8 and okay if
this point is attacked twice but what
luck is also attacking the c2 pond so we
also definitely doesn't want to capture
here but this allows the sir a very nice
idea he plays the night to d4 now
threatening Knight to c6 what a fork
under King Queen and the rook so rook to
d7 by Karpov and now Knight to c6
forking the Queen and this a seven point
we have 28 and now
Yassir wrapped this pawn so Karpov was
up upon when he grabbed this be to the
pawn but well this was in the position
and this Knights Knights journey to a7
was unstoppable
so he's not really up upon anymore I
would have worked the c7 and Yasser gets
a brilliant idea here
he plays a four and it seems like now
yasser blundered a piece as Karpov plays
Queen to a8 and now there is no way to
well defend this night but Yassir had
this all planned out he plays rook
captures on d5 and I'll threatens all
all sorts of discoveries from this
Bishop to the Queen
so okay Karpov captures the knight Queen
captures on a7 and here yasser plays
rook to d8 would check we have a kink to
h8 a kinked h7 only move and now quinta
d3 again with a check and where's the
black king gonna go he can either play
g6 or maybe f5 but let's see what
happens g if g 6 is played as this is
much more interesting if g6 is played
then Queen to d4 now with an attack on
this row can be too and also threatening
checkmate here on h7 on h8 sorry rook to
be one is only moved because this is
check Oh King to g2 but now winter h8
checkmate is still threatening so have
success to be played any other simply
Queen captures on f6 the threat of
checkmate on h8 is still there so rub
the g7 and I've simply Queen to f8
threatening checkmate again on h8 g 5
bishop the bishop d4 with check rocked
g6 Queen to g8 checkmate
so although this is a I don't know it's
it's a combination of maybe six or seven
moves but it's a pretty easy combination
to calculate so after Queen three three
check carp of trial at five but now we
are simply captured their Queen captures
and f5g sex is forced and now Queen the
e6 and in this position
Karpov resigned because if you try to
stop this Queen to g8 checkmate anyway
for example rook to f7 you get Bishop
three four now threatening and g6 and
now the rock has to go here and Queen to
e8 and this is over there is no move
that stops Queen h8 checkmate okay you
do have rugby one check just sacrificing
the rock and prolonging checkmate for
one move but of course the world
champion Karpov doesn't doesn't allow
this
so after Queen to e6 Karpov said good
game yessir you're the man and then then
carp carp who explained why he lost the
game he said that well his companion
Geller was actually preparing him for
every game and this morning Geller went
you know shopping for groceries and he
was out for the entire morning and he
didn't prepare carp or food for this
game and Karpov well I wasn't prepared
and so he lost as as he did so yeah
definitely good game good game by uh sir
but but also good game Geller so yeah
thank you for watching this is it for
this video a lot of people have asked me
to show a Yasir game and what better
game to show then then a victory over
over the reigning world champion so yeah
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon